[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui j'ai une grosse folie
puisque c'est la rentrée des classes ah
ouais bah elle à la rentrée des classes
mais moi je me rappelle quand je vous
dis la rentrée des classes ça devrait
mains sur la tête de ma mère
ma mère elle m'amenait à rosny brille la
veille
je m'en rappelle pas ce qu'il fallait
que je sois très beau gosse juste pour
la rentrée des clarisses est vrai et je
peux vous dire quand vous sortie aux
lilas avec un sac ronis ronnie brion
respectèrent
on est pris aux lilas ce n'était pas le
monde
c'est un truc de ouf me rappelle un jour
amer elle m'a acheté une chemise à
carreaux jaune comme ça il ya un peu
genre rech aa été il faisait froid pour
la rentrée des classes donc j'ai dit à
ses apports au look est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai dit j'ai mis un blouson et par
dessus j'ai mis la miche
je voulais pas lâcher tu vois j'ai mis
l'accent dessus mais la rentrée des
classes si tu raques la rentrée des
classes tu expliques c'est sur les deux
premiers jours que tu te fais remarquer
si au niveau des meufs au niveau des mec
t'es pas dedans c'est arlette je pêche
aura pas toute l'année mais je te le
dire on peut certes toujours des phrases
quant à ryanair auprès des clubs non
j'ai rouge nous on y chante et joue
pareil qui fait plein de tester sur
table ça va être la galère non mais tu
connais pas ça soit réglé il ya toujours
des bagarres j'espère que tu auras pas
fassbender ou chimio
à ben t'es [ __ ] excécrable un pays il ya
toujours un mec en fait qui connaît les
potins dont tout le monde s'en fout mais
genre des profs tu veux nous pas moi je
me rabats époque c'était thomas brisson
c'est vrai notre admin et où thomas
brisson bien sûr je m'en rappelle et il
connaissait tout sur les profs mois
ouais ouais ouais se dit tiens gg da
costa en allemand je dis d'ailleurs da
costa n'était pas prouvée d'espagne a
même dit nono en fait elle est en couple
avec monsieur heinrich ans
c
la changer elle fait plus d'espagnols et
prof d'allemand à la trottier elle a
troqué la troupe sillas pour le strudel
scellé avec sortait des novateurs et moi
je me rappelle moi j'ai fait mon premier
relais à bon port est bien sûr vous avez
à ce que je dis mais pas ce que je
kiffais une meuf
en fait il fallait parce que c'était
jour et mélanie gaudin ils s'aiment pas
de se rappeler de tous les prénoms c'est
bien sûr parce qu'on a fait la semaine
dernière mais la passe est bien sûr
disent les gens dans toute notre vie
quand je suis en primaire ou au collège
anigo dans trop content de toi t'as
jamais redoublé mois les gages et
[Applaudissements]
mélanie gaulle à ce que tu savais pas
c'est que cette
fois il était le seul gars voiture au
qatar
moi j'ai ramené les poches
à côté je raccroche désormais notamment
entre moi j'ai fait allemand pour le
maroc ce que je voulais être avec
mélanie grenon alors du coup mélanie
goddam sendrès à bord des larmes alors
j'ai fait allemand est en fait allemand
j'ai fait quatre ans d'allemand et le la
seule chose que je sais dire en allemand
trônant sur la tête de ma mère artaud
c'est une chose mais ça veut dire je
vais rappeler
[Applaudissements]
c'est monsieur projet tuteuré un jour il
a eu une meuf et on l'appelait la meuf
fauché
une étaient ils étaient genre est
agressé tu vois il dit à al houla genre
qu'est ce qu'a fait hier j'ai vu
[Rires]
sur la toile
le mec le droit de le calmer je me suis
approché il faisait 2 mètres et genre
même ses chaussures elle est allemande
c'est à dire j'ai pas elle était en
boitant
j'aurai quand il rentrait drague
d'affaires et il fait rire comme ça hp
comme j'habite john dira asseyez vous
mettiez way et moi je restais debout à
le rebelle qua non parce que je
comprenais pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà mekkaoui mois thierry route genk
est un mec devant daté d'aujourd'hui qui
se dit il ya 20 ans j'étais à côté assis
à côté de ce looser ringarde la dame n'a
aujourd'hui c'est lui
et si tu as fait ton retour pour mon
fils il
fait mal
peut-être que mélanie gaudord maugrée
n'a été retrouvée il va retrouver
patrick sabatier qui
était sonnée ouais non non non et refera
pas là et la seat je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais
beaucoup plus à l'est que les ont
quittés comme
[Rires]
nous rappeler en classe sans déconner
mais quand le prof il est genre 8h30 là
et on doit à l'emploi et tu vois le 8h32
le prof n'est pas encore génial et là
moi je me rappelle je lancé et les mecs
moi je veux bien que tu tiens il sera
pas à 8h35 je considère le porte comme
définitive
la rentrée des classes franchement c'est
un moment exceptionnel moi je me
rappelle j'allais acheter mon cartable
frais ah oui on dirait que j'allais
acheter une maison frère il restait pas
de bataille
mais perd le cartable tu sais que tu vas
l'avoir donc l'année c log à un cartable
moi je me rappelle et j'avais pris un
cartable à chaque fois je prenais des
cartables genre avec des animaux mais un
peu chelou tu vois alors j'aurai un loup
comme ça
et je me rappelle y avait toujours un
mec de ma classe il avait joué dans un
sac en toile us avec le à doha darche il
s'appelait content quand as tu te mets à
côté de moi au tp de cinoche paris schp
rester seul j'en ai marre de cette
classe l'année dernière on rigolait aux
fumées à l'intér classe cette année avec
des loosers non mais c'est vrai il ya
quinze jours le canton qui suivent sa
chérie non mais vous avez fait allemand
première langue normalement c'est
réservé aux bons éléments et aux bons
élèves comment vous avez fait alors
[Musique]
alors on sait ce qu'on peut on choisir
moment oui mais ça dépend des moyennes
ont choisi alors des moyennes fall et
moyenne gamme et moyenne officielle
moyenne que je fais moi même
il a tenté parfois ça faut pas le faire
moi j'avais des faux bulletins pour ma
mère pour ma mère et les vrais pour ben
pour moi
parce que moi je savais ce que je valais
et je me rappellerai toujours les faux
bulletins étaient tellement bien fait
que un jour il ya une meuf à la famille
fournier dans ma poche elle avoue mon
faux bulletins elle a regardé mon [ __ ]
comme ça l'a fait
je travaille hyper bien
et je lui ai toujours dit ma mère m'a
cramé le jour je m'en rappelle j'ai mis
une appréciation c'était en maths j'ai
rien 18 mai dessus parce que je partais
de 2 le gars c'est en voyant l'air assez
bon et quand le jour où est le jour où
j'ai mis profil de polytechniciens
arrêté ma mère a dit
je vais quand même aller vérifier sur
place
les actes
c'est que je me rappelle j'étais sorti
ce jour-là l'unicef enfin j'avais 25 ans
et j'envoie ma mère au loin au avec des
papiers dans la main
l'angoissé ma mère a ride j'étais en
train de faire le beau gosse à elle
arrive elle fait c'est quoi ça un moment
qu'on est vrai bulletin et la fin quand
je ne comprends pas
je dois d'abord une erreur quelque part
est tous et pas du tout ce que tu crois
pas